[Musique]
il ya eu bien des catastrophes maritimes
mais nul n'a captivé l'imagination du
public de façon aussi intense et aussi
vivace que celle du titanic il faisait
l'orgueil de sa compagnie la white star
line
c'était le plus grand navire du monde sa
collision avec un iceberg lors de son
voyage inaugural et son naufrage qui
causa la perte de quelque 1500 personnes
lui ont valu sa place dans l'histoire
[Musique]
les événements tragiques d'havré 1912
sont inoubliables plus jamais les hommes
n'accorderait une confiance illimitée à
la technologie on avait affirmé dans la
presse qu'il était insubmersible son
naufrage constitua une sévère leçon pour
le monde
la légende du titanic vit encore dans la
mémoire des hommes et elle grandit à
chaque fois qu'elle est relaté
mais revenons aux premières années de
notre siècle et retraçons la naissance
de ce paquebot géant et de ses frères
car il est des trois navires
à l'époque édouardienne la
grande-bretagne construit la moitié des
navires marchands du monde
sa construction navale et son génie
ferroviaires sont inégalées dans le
monde et ses possessions à travers le
globe fond de l'empiré britannique le
plus grand que le monde ait jamais connu
pl empire sur lequel le soleil ne se
couche jamais
la route commerciale la plus lucrative
et celle rognons l'amérique du nord
l'atlantique nord devient ainsi la
principale victime est la plus
importante pour le trafic passagers à
cette époque il n'y a pas de
restrictions à l'entrée des migrants
européens dans le nouveau monde et des
milliers font la traversée la
grande-bretagne rivalisent
principalement avec l'allemagne dans la
construction des plus grands des plus
rapides et des plus luxueux paquebot
afin de s'attirer ton les voyageurs
fortunés que le lucratif trafic des
migrants
dès 1906 l'allemagne possède tant le
plus grand paquebot le kaiser in august
victoria de 24500 80 une tonne que le
plus rapide
le kaiser ville m2 d'une vitesse de 23
noeuds 2,6 en 1907 la grande bretagne
les éclipses tous les deux avec les
paquebot de la cunard du lusitania et
mauritaniens jauge en tout 2 32 mille
tonnes et d'une vitesse dépassant 26
noeuds ils ont été construits grâce à
des subventions du ministère de la
marine qui souhaitent rétablir la
supériorité britannique et empêcher la
cunard d' d'être racheté par un cartel
américain lynch nos marques et à laurine
campagne i lya men et subventions
signifiant en outre que les deux
paquebots pourront être converties en
temps de guerre en croiseur auxiliaire
armée le cmx team navigation campanie
plus connu sous le nom de white star
line est déjà sous contrôle financier
américain cette compagnie a choisi de ne
pas participer à la course pour
construire les paquebots les plus
rapides mais d'accorder la priorité au
confort et à la sécurité
le soutien américain a permis à la
compagnie de se lancer dans un projet
ambitieux la construction de trois
paquebots qui assureront un service
hebdomadaire à travers l'atlantique
ils seront les navires les plus grands
et plus luxueux et les plus sûrs du
monde de dimension supérieure de 50% au
géant de la cunard d' ils seront
baptisés olympique titanic et gigue
antique
ce dernier devenant plus tard le
britannique
la commande des deux premiers navires
est passé le 1er juillet 1907 avec les
chantiers arland et wolf de bell face
ils obtiennent les numéros de chantier
400 et 401 d'importantes modifications
chantiers navals de queens island sont
nécessaires trois cales de constructions
existantes sont démolis et remplacés par
deux nouvelles call celles ci sont en
jambes et par un portique offrant des
espaces libres de 30 mètres entre des
rangées de tours porteuse le portique
long de 256 mètres et surmontés d'une
grue mobile d'une portée de 41 mètres et
d'une capacité de levage de trois tonnes
6 échafaudage mobile porte chacun dit
grue radial dotés d'ascenseurs et de
rampes pour transporter hommes et
matériaux aux divers niveaux de
construction un grand ponton grue sera
achetée en allemagne et l'on entame la
construction d'une nouvelle cale sèche
le nombre des employés du chantier naval
double atteignant 11 mille trois cents
hommes durant la construction et
l'armement des deux immenses paquebots
l'architecte des navires et thomas and
jews neveu de l'aude thierry le
président d'euroland et wolf
c'est un membre en vue de la bonne
société irlandaise
il travaille avec son adjoint edouard
baer holding dans un bureau d'étude
grouillant de dessinateurs qui contient
une énorme maquette de la cote de
navires envisager la pose de la quille
de l'olympique intervient le 1er janvier
1909 celle du titanic le 16 mars la
construction des deux énormes coque
progresse rapidement
l'olympique avec quelques mois d'avancé
sur le titanic pour alléger la tâche des
ateliers de production du chantier naval
olympique est lancée le 20 octobre 1910
il est peinte en gris pour donner aux
photographes de presse de meilleure vue
du paquebot et son lancement prend à
peine soixante deux secondes
il est ensuite remorqué jusqu'au nouveau
quai en eau profonde pour être armés
laissant derrière lui le titanic à la
coque peintes en noir encore prisonnier
de son portique
ces nouveaux bâtiments sont conçus pour
des vitesses de croisière de 21 noeuds
les machines fournissent une puissance
de 55 mille chevaux la cunard a choisi
les turbines marines pour propulser ses
navire briseur de record mais arland et
wolf adopte sa combinaison favorite des
machines alternative qui entraîne les
deux davis externe de 7 mètres de
diamètre dont la vapeur est ensuite
transmise à une turbine basse pression
qui actionne les lys centrales de 5
mètres prévus pour la marche avant la
vapeur et fournit aux machines par 24
chaudière à deux bouts et cinq
chaudières à bout unique contenant 159
foyer
sept mois après son lancement le grand
navire est prêt après deux jours d
essais à la mer concluant l'olympique
quitte enfin belfast le 31 mai 1911
c'est une opération publicitaire calculé
à la perfection puisque le titanic
lui-même est finalement lancé le même
jour
pour l'occasion le drapeau britannique
et le drapeau américain ont été déployés
sur l'extrémité du côté de la terre du
portique de construction avec au centre
la flamme de la white star sous laquelle
des pavillons heppell le mot succès
peu après 12h15 sous le regard de près
de cent mille personnes
le paquebot poussé par des vérins
hydrauliques glisse en arrière dans le
fleuve la gamme la cérémonie brève comme
de coutume à la white storm plus tard
lorsque le britannique sera lancé un
employé du chantier naval à la retraite
dira il les construisent et ils les
jettent à la flotte
en 62 secondes à peine le paquebot
glisse dans l'eau puis il est immobilisé
par les tonnes de chaîne attachée par
des câbles le long de sa coque
le lendemain le 1er juillet son jumeau
jette l'ancré dans l'estuaire de la
meuse et près de liverpool port
d'attache et d'armements de toujours de
la white star line
ce sera sa seule visite à la meuse et
puisqu'il fera route ensuite pour 120
tonnes port principal de la compagnie
depuis 1907 où la london south walton
railway a construit un nouveau bassin de
grande dimension pour recevoir cette
nouvelle cote de one chip merveille des
merveilles deux fois plus grande que les
paquebots de 20 mille tonnes auxquelles
le port est habitué le bassin appelé
white star d'orques jusqu'à la fin des
années vingt mesures 518 m de long 121
mètres de large et a une superficie de 6
hectares et demi par la suite il sera
utilisé par des paquebots tels que le
queen mary le queen elizabeth et enfin
le nouveau cube tous les chantiers randy
wolf ont construit un atelier de
réparation à southampton
mais les grosses réparations devront
être effectués dans la nouvelle cale
sèche de belfast
[Musique]
l'olympique entreprend son voyage
inaugural le mercredi 14 juin à midi son
commandant est à john smit le capitaine
le plus expérimenté de la compagnie
destiné au commandement de son navire
jumeau à bord se trouvent également jay
bruce ismay y le président de la
compagnie il prépare un rapport
méticuleux sur l'agencement les
installations et le service du navire de
nombreuses modifications de ses
fournitures seront par la suite apporté
au titanic
[Musique]
les changements les plus importants on
concerne le pont promenade b où seront
rajoutés des appartements privés l'ubs
se s'étendant sur le flanc du paquebot
éliminant par là la galerie sur presque
toute sa longueur et augmentant la jauge
brute 2004 tonnes à hall d'accueil près
du grand escalier arrière un grand
restaurant avec vue sur la mer et un
café parisien
doté de treillages ou g du lierre
[Musique]
les deux navires sont pourvus
d'ascenseur électriques ou de piscine
alors qu'une innovation au maire de
peinture
deux courts de squash et de gymnases
mais le titanic a la réputation d'être
encore plus luxueux du fait de ses
nombreuses améliorations
des lambris et richement sculpté des
vitraux des tapis de hautes plaines et
bien d'autres éléments temps nécessaire
que luxueux viennent parachever le
titanic
ce sera un palace flottant
[Musique]
mais son achèvement et par conséquent la
date de son voyage inaugural sont
retardés en raison du retour de
l'olympique à belfast
suite à une collision avec le croiseur
ait jamais aucun le 20 septembre près de
sarnen la proue du haut et très
endommagée l'olympique à une déchirure
de 12 mètres de haut qui s'étend sur 2
mètres 40 à l'intérieur du navire
il y à une seconde brèche à la ligne de
flottaison provoquée par les pros du
croiseur certains témoins affirment que
l'énorme masse du paquebot a provoqué en
courant sous marin qui a aspiré le petit
navire dans son flanc plus tard ce
phénomène manquera de provoquer une
collision au départ du titanic de
sardanes
l'olympique est emmené à la nouvelle
cale sèche de belfast et des sommes
affectées à l'armement du titanic sont
appelés pour hâter les réparations le 24
février 1912
l'olympique il retournera pour une
réparation à son délice suite à ces
retards et 11 - après son lancement le
titanic est enfin prêt pour les essais à
la mer
les modifications final a été de couvrir
et de vitré la promenade avant dupont a
sur l'olympique cette section tendent à
être mouillés par les embruns
cette caractéristique visuel du titanic
le distingue de son jumeau les essais
débutent le 2 avril en mer d'irlande
sous le commandement de son capitaine ed
jones mais qu'il est sans l'olympique
hasarde hampton s'est rendu à belfast
il prend là le meilleur est l'ultime
commandement de sa carrière et va
emmener le paquebot à saint wendel en
raison des aménagements de dernière
minute à son intérieur
celui ci n'est pas ouvert à l'examen du
public comme il est coutume le navire
est minutieusement inspectée par un
représentant du ministère du commerce
les embarcations de sauvetage flambant
neuf sont mis à l'eau qu'on leur fait
faire un tour de bassin à la rame à la
satisfaction de l'inspecteur puelles
sont hissés à bord les embarcations sont
manoeuvrés par des baux soir à
basculement est bien que ces derniers
soient capables de mettre à la mer
plusieurs embarcations tour à tour en
cas d'urgence le nombre effectif
d'embarcations de sauvetage installé sur
le titanic est conforme à une
réglementation du ministère du commerce
établit vingt ans auparavant
celle-ci fixé à 16 le nombre
d'embarcations de sauvetage que devait
transporter un navire de 10 mille tonnes
ou plus un bâtiment d'envergure pour la
fin du 19e siècle et le titanic jauge 46
mille tonnes
la white star fournira en fait quatre
canaux supplémentaires des berton de
type carte à fond à planches et flan
pliant toile
le nombre de passagers n'est pas prise
en compte seule la lettre de la loi est
suivie en fait ce n'est que la moitié du
nombre d'embarcations de sauvetage
requis pour un effectif complet de
passagers et membres d'équipage dans
l'éventualité d'un naufrage
le capitaine smith est le doyen des
capitaines de la white store cela fait
de longues années qu'on lui confie le
commandement des navires de la white
star line lors de leur voyage inaugural
il est né le 27 janvier 1850 à alliston
contrainte il est le fils de will smith
un potier qui deviendra un marchand de
légumes et de catherine m il a fait ses
études à l'étrier à british school un
des premiers externat du district des
poteries
il est d'abord employé comme opérateur
de marteau pilon à vapeur à la forge
d'être ya mais ils quittent la région à
l'âge de 21 ans pour entrer dans la
marine marchande
sa progression est si rapide qu'on lui
confie le commandement de son premier
navire à 24 ans au fil d'une carrière
exceptionnelle
il finit par être nommé commandant puis
doyen des capitaines de la white star
line ses employeurs ont une confiance
totale en ses compétences et son
jugement sa carrière n'a été ternie par
aucun accident
si ce n'est l'incident sur l'olympic
c'est un homme de haute taille distingué
à la voix douce
al'approche de sa retraite le titanic
devait être le couronnement de sa
carrière
[Musique]
depuis janvier 1912 le pays est paralysé
par une grève des mineurs qui a provoqué
la mise en rade de nombreux paquebots et
a mis dix sept mille hommes au chômage à
sandton
dès le mois d'avril la grève tire à sa
fin et pour permettre au titanic de
prendre la mer il est nécessaire de
débarquer du charbon d'autres navires en
rade dans les docks le scénic et le
majestic de la white star ainsi que le
new york le philadelphia le saint louis
est le symbole de l'américaine l'arrêt
[Musique]
le mercredi 10 avril des centaines de
passagers et d'hommes d'équipage montent
à bord du titanic
c'est une belle journée ensoleillée le
train assurant la correspondance avec
londres amène les gens fortunés dont le
millionnaire benjamines guggenheim et
l'éditeur de las palmas gazette williams
ted qui seront en amérique
sur l'invitation du président taft pour
prononcer un discours à la conférence
mondiale de la paix le 22 avril
[Musique]
toutes les couches de la société sont
représentés sur ce navire palais
certains passagers ont été transférés
des navires mis en rade de lier même la
famille desmarais avait à l'origine
réservé des places sur le philadelphia
nous avions retenu une cabine à bord
d'un autre navire le philadelphia et
puis il ya eu cette grève des mineurs et
il n'a pas pris la mer on nous a ensuite
offert une cabine sur le titanic
ce qui est absolument ravie mon père
c'était merveilleux le monde entier
parler de ce paquebot mais ma mère a eu
cet horrible prémonition elle n'avait
jamais eu auparavant et ne plus jamais
après mais elle nous dit non nous ne
pouvons pas faire cela c'est impossible
une chose terrible va se passer je vais
vous dire quel type de femme s'était
elle avait les pieds sur terre qu'elle
agisse ainsi était incroyable pour tout
le monde mais elle a simplement eu cette
prémonition
moi j'avais 7 ans j'avais lu qu'il y
avait un grand navire mais cela n'avait
pas vraiment autant de sens pour moi que
pour mes parents naturellement je
n'étais jamais monté sur un bateau cela
n'évoquez pas grand chose pour moi je
savais toutefois que tout le monde en
parlait à midi on largue les amarres
retenant le paquebot hockey et six
remorqueurs les lois une lentement du
quai des acclamations fusent de la foule
assemblée là on agite des mouchoirs et
des messages de dernière minute sont
échangées entre le navire et le quai le
titanic s'engage dans la rivière tests
et commence à naviguer par ses propres
moyens
ces trois hélices propulsant lentement
en avant ses 46 mille tonnes mais il
déplace une telle quantité d'eau dans le
chenal que le paquebot new york
amarré près de l'océanic brice et amar
et dérives en arrière vers le navire
géant
le capitaine smith et le pilote georges
borias arrête les lys centrale et
ordonne que les hélices externe soit
mise en arrière tout cela immobilise de
new york alors qu'il est qu à trois
mètres cinquante de la poupe du titanic
tandis que le grand paquebot suspens
aussi ça marche
le remorqueur val kahn se plaçant entre
les vaisseaux demande qu'on lance des
cordes sur le new york est comme le
titanic recul maintenant légèrement
remorque le new york autour du bassin
jusqu'à la rivière ritchen le mettant
hors de danger
la collision ont manqué est perçu par
beaucoup comme un mauvais présage et
retarde à nouveau bien que de peu son
départ le paquebot poursuit sa route le
long de la sardane ce nouveau ca
dépassant à m
à tribord et west show net les sons ab
en ruine et son immense hôpital
militaire à bâbord
il passe l'embouchure de la rivière
rambo est double enfin un chaos chaude
speed puis entre dans le chenal du salat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sous un soleil radieux le titanic base
case et l'île de wight entre dans la
pleine mer et file en direction de
cherbourg qu'il doit joindre à 18h30
pour embarquer des sacs postaux et des
passagers
[Musique]
parmi ces derniers se trouvent d'autres
millionnaires tels john jacob astor et
son épouse ainsi que divergents du monde
certains voyant dans le voyage inaugural
du plus grand paquebot du monde
une excellente manière d'achever leurs
vacances en europe
à présent le titanic via un cap à
l'ouest à travers la manche et fait
escale à queen's tarn
aujourd'hui comme en irlande le 11 avril
peu avant midi d'autres sacs postaux
sont embarqués et l'on débarque du
courrier et des passagers dans le port
irlandais
[Applaudissements]
il reste à bord du titanic 322 passagers
de première classe
deux cent soixante dix sept passagers de
seconde classe et 709 de troisième
classe
il est donc à moitié plein ainsi que 8
198 membres d'équipage 3814 sacs postaux
ont été embarqués dont une partie sera
trié dans la propre poste du titanic
le paquebot lève l'anc à 13h30 et
pénètre dans l'atlantique
mettons le cap sur new york
[Musique]
la vie à bord d'un transatlantique
consiste à se restaurer et à s'occuper
du mieux possible entre les repas les
premières classes ont l'agrément d'un
orchestre de cinq musiciens dirigés par
voilà ça entre les
précédemment rentrent les a joués sur le
mauritania et d'autres prestigieux
paquebot alors qu'istres joue un
répertoire très varié aussi bien strauss
offenbach dans la majestueuse giacobbi
et drum que des airs de ragtime et des
call box pour l'été dans son
un trio séparer joue dans la salle de
réception du restaurant et le café
parisien
un piano est mise à la disposition des
passagers de la troisième classe et un
joueur de pipeau et un joueur de violon
irlandais animent leurs danses
les jeux de ballons sur les ponts à
coffre avant et arrière sont populaires
parmi les passagers de la troisième
classe
ils peuvent être suivis depuis les ponts
supérieurs par des spectateurs des
autres classes eux mêmes ont largement
la place de jouer au tennis au calais ou
de se promener le long du large pont des
embarcations
à l'intérieur il y à des bibliothèques
et des salons de jeux de première et
seconde classe
pour restaurer plus de 2000 personnes en
mer durant ces jours le chef cuisinier
monsieur propre tas a stocké à bord 34
mille kilos de viandes diverses
onze mille trois cents kilos de volaille
donc à y faisant poulets dindes et
pluviers quinze mille bouteilles de
bière et 1000 bouteilles de vin 450 kg
de thé 990 kg de café et des tonnes de
fruits de légumes de confiture et
d'autres aliments
en troisième classe la nourriture est
simple mais abondante on a affirmé que
la troisième classe du titanic vallée la
première classe de tout autre paquebot
il y a deux salles à manger pour les
premières classes là giacobbi et blum et
le resteront à la carte
attenant au café parisien les deux
derniers étant gérée par monsieur gatti
et son personnel pour le compte de la
white star un clairon sonne l'appelle le
soir pour le dîner
[Musique]
durant la traversée le ton demeure au
beau fixe
la mairie calme mais la brise et fraîche
le dimanche 14 avril
le temps va se refroidir au poste radio
télégraphique le contact entre le navire
et la côte est à nouveau rendu possible
puisque le titanic arrive en vue du cap
rex les opérateurs sont fort occupés
avec les messages en cours et ceux qui
se sont accumulés en raison d'une panne
du système de jours auparavant
le dimanche les deux opérateurs du poste
radio télé graphique de type marconi
jake phillips et son adjoint alors pride
ont reçu des avis de glace leur tâche
principale consiste à transmettre et
recevoir des messages privés nommé
marconi g des informations concernant la
bourse de londres et des nouvelles
ces messages privés produisant des
revenus pour la compagnie les messages
officiels que reçoit le navire signale
la présence de pâques rise de petits et
de grands experts dans les couloirs de
navigation
bien que l'on ne réalise pas que ces
avis font état d'un immense champ de
glace les messages destinés aux navires
sont épinglés sur un tableau d'affichage
pour l'information des officiers de
navigation
mais tous les avis de glace ne seront
pas affichés à 11 heures un message
indique america passé le 14 avril en vue
de deux gros iceberg par 41° 27 latitude
nord et 50° 8 longitude ouest
un message reçu du mesa ba à 9h40
prévient glaz signalé l'attitude 42
degrés à 41° 25 nord longitude à 49
degrés à 50° 30 ouest avons vu quantité
de grosses masses de paca rice et grand
nombre de grands iceberg champs de glace
également temps beau et claire
l'opérateur a joy ride n'est pas de
quart mais l'opérateur en chef jacques
philips est submergé par la quantité de
messages privés qui doit envoyer et
recevoir il mais ce dernier message de
côté en attend d'être livré à la
passerelle
il ne pouvait pas savoir que ce message
signaler la présence de glace
directement sur la route du titanic à
23h le paquebot californienne de la lay
line se trouve non loin de là bloqués
par la glace en cours de soirée
philips rabroue vertement l'opérateur
marconi du californian pour avoir
interrompu ses appels au café rex plus
tard quand il quitte son service
l'opérateur radio du californienne est à
son poste et va se coucher
le capitaine smith s'est rendu à un
dîner donné en son honneur dans le
restaurant il retourne à la passerelle à
21h ils discutent du temps et des avis
de glace avec l'officiant se vante
charles harvey larry charles à 20
minutes plus tard ils seront dans la
chambre des cartes laissant des
instructions pour qu'on l'appelle si les
conditions se dégradent et la ritalin
qui son service à 22 heures passant le
relais aux premiers officiers madoff ait
fana se couche un peu avant 23h30 après
avoir fait sa ronde du navire
sur la une de vigie les veilleurs
frédéric fleet et red road lit regarde
devant te dans le vent glacé à 23h40
fleet sonne par trois fois la cloche la
une et téléphone au poste de commande
[Musique]
heitz bach droit devant s'exclame-t-il
il décrit ce qu'il aperçoit l'iceberg se
rapproche
le navire répond alors aux instructions
d'urgence demain donc barre à droite
toute
en arrière tout d'abord tout
[Musique]
l'étrave vire lentement et les bugs
glisse contre le flanc de tri bord du
navire avant de disparaître à l'arrière
la collision semble avoir été évité de
justesse
mais l'iceberg a heurté la coque du
navire sous la ligne de flottaison
arrachant les têtes dérivés pénétrant en
certaine partie de la coque et ouvrant
les joints des plaques d'acier
il a pratiqué une déchirure longue de 75
à 90 mètres sous la ligne de flottaison
le long de la partie frontale de la
coque tribord l'impact n'a pris que 10
secondes
[Musique]
beaucoup de passagers n'ont rien
remarqué
d'autres diront avoir ressenti une
légère vibration certaines personnes
montent sur le pont pour voir pourquoi
le navire s'immobilise et sur le pont
dès troisième classe on voit des hommes
jouer au football sur le pont à coffre
avant avec des blocs de glace qui se
sont détachés au passage de l'immense
montagne de glace
il n'y a aucun signe du désastre
imminent
le commandant ce mets s'est précipité
sur la passerelle pour vérifier que
toutes les portes étanches à commande
électrique ont été fermées et ordonne
une rapide inspection du navire
ce n'est qu'à ce moment-là que
l'énormité des avaries à sa coque se
fait jour le titanic est divisé en 16
compartiments étanches et peut continuer
à flotter avec deux compartiments à la
rigueur trois ou quatre entièrement
inondées mais du fait de ce long shot
oblique les six compartiments avant ont
été envahies par d'importantes voies
d'eau à sa distance de la proue les
cloisons étanches n'atteignent que le
pont des premières classes certaines
même pas aussi haut et à mesure que le
navire s'alourdit j'ai fait de l'eau de
mer qui pénètrent à flot et qu'il
commence à piquer du nez
l'eau monte au dessus de ses
compartiments et inondent le suivant et
puis le suivant et ainsi de suite
le naufrage du titanic est inévitable
toi moi san jose l'architecte du navire
en apport confirmation au commandant ce
mets mais des passagers ignore encore le
péril imminent
j'étais couché bien sûr ma mère est
revenu et a décrit ce qui se passait
dans les salons ce soir là mon père
s'est énervé il avait de bonnes raisons
de détester le jeu
son père avait été un joueur invétéré
était mort sans le sou bien qu'étant
départ nomme fortunés et donc tout le
monde jouée ce dimanche soit il faisait
des paris sur l'heure à laquelle le
paquebot arriverait combien de minutes
et cetera mon père ne voulait rien avoir
à faire avec cela
alors il s'est couché tôt ce soir là
pour lui en tout cas
et ma mère s'est installée pour coudre
et pour lire la regarder il visait et
lui a dit que c'était un livre
intéressant mais il s'est endormi assez
vite et elle s'élevait lui apprit le
livre et sert aziz elle a dit qu à 23h50
elle avait senti un léger choc et elle a
dit que c'était comme lorsqu'un train
s'immobilise
après être entré en gare savait juste
secouer un peu
c'était très léger mais elle m'a dit
qu'elle a su alors que c'était cette
chose horrible et elle a réveillé mon
père qui a dit que non ils ne montraient
pas à nouveau sur le pont après ce qui
s'était passé mais elle a littéralement
tiré du lit elle a fait monter voir ce
qui se passait puis elle a dit qu'elle
allait m'habiller et comme j'avais
sommeil j'ai été désobéissante et j'ai
dit que je ne voulais pas qu'elle
mabille
mon père est revenu très vite parce
qu'ils pouvaient monter sur le pont
rapidement grâce à l'ascenseur il m'a
soulevé emma enveloppé bien serré dans
une couverture
comme si j'étais un bébé et ma mère ne
lui a rien dit je lui ai demandé parfois
bien des années plus tard je ne
comprends pas pourquoi tu ne l'a pas dit
qu'est ce que c'était ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait et elle disait je n'avais pas
besoin de demander ce que c'était je ne
savais pas ce que c'était mais je savais
que c'était cette chose horrible que
j'avais dû porter en moins depuis des
mois
que pouvais-je rajouter d'autres donc il
doit passer un épais manteau et en a
endossé un lieu aussi sans prononcer un
mot
et nous sommes sortis de la cabine nous
avons pris l'ascenseur et nous sommes
sortis sur le pont si nous n'avions pas
fait cela à ce moment là je doute que je
serai en train de vous parler
aujourd'hui parce que comme vous le
savez il y avait de la place pour moins
de 800 personnes dans les canots de
sauvetage et le navire en transporter
2200 c'était donc à qui étaient là à
temps pour monter dans un des trop rares
canaux mais ils ne furent pas mis à la
mer très rapidement parce qu'au départ
personne ne pensait que cela allait
vraiment se passer mais mon père est
allé parler à un officier qu'il va dit
ils vont mettre les canots de sauvetage
à la mer mais vous serez de retour à
bord pour le petit-déjeuner l'alertent
général est alors donné des messages et
parcourt le navire invitant les gens à
mettre leur gilet de sauvetage et à
monter sur le pont certains pensent
encore qu'il s'agit simplement d'un
exercice de sauvetage même aux environs
de minuit au départ l'opération est
caractérisée par l'ordre et la
discipline les gens demeurant dans
l'ensemble assez calme dans la nuit
froide claire et étoilé le pont se
rempli de passagers ceux des classes
supérieures arrive avant les effectifs
plus importants des 3e classe dont les
cabines sont les plus éloignés du pont
des embarcations
la mer est très calme mais le capitaine
smith c'est qu'il n'y aura assez place
dans les canaux que pour la moitié des
personnes à bord au poste de tsf le
commandant ordonne aux opérateurs de se
tenir prêts puis revient à quelques
minutes plus tard à 00h15 leur demander
d'envoyer le signal de détresse
international cqt la position du navire
est estimé à 41 degrés 46 latitude nord
50° 24 longitude ouest à 00h25
elle passe à 41 degrés 46 nord 50° 14
ouest le signalera
lisez ayant été capté par le paquebot
carpathia à 60 milles environ
il change immédiatement de cap et fait
route vers le géant détresse peu après
00h30 le commandant smith revient à la
salle radio et ils demandent ce qu'ils
envoient sécu des réponses philips lance
en plaisantant envoie un sos c'est le
nouveau signal ce sera peut-être la
dernière chance de l'envoyer peu après
la première embarcation est mis à la mer
elle contient seulement 19 à 20
personnes
à aucun moment de la traversée un
exercice de sauvetage n'a été effectué
avec les passagers et beaucoup d'hommes
d'équipage ne sont pas certains de la
localisation de leurs postes de
sauvetage c'est alors que le maître de
manoeuvre l'homme commence envoyer des
fusées de détresse à des intervalles de
cinq minutes
désormais les gens rient chine - à
monter dans les embarcations de
sauvetage que l'on se prépare à mettre à
l'eau l'évacuation du navire cesse
maintenant d'être calme et ordonnée il
n'y avait pas de panique jusqu'à ce que
les canaux quitte le navire
alors ce fut une véritable panique nous
étions en bas sur l'océan et nous
pouvions entendre les gens courir sur le
pont en criant vous imaginez et jean
montée de leurs cabinets voyez qu'il n'y
avait pas de canot de sauvetage et il se
précipitait de l'autre côté c'est là que
la panique a commencé
il n'y avait pas de panique au moment je
suis monté dans un canot parce qu'il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de gens sur le pont
et qu'il y avait suffisamment de canaux
pour les gens présents mais après
lorsque les autres ont commencé à monter
de leur cabine et qu'il n'y avait plus
de canaux montus c'était une véritable
panique alors qu'istres du paquebot
dirigé par voilà cinq les jouets à
l'intérieur à présent les musiciens
sortent sur le pont et de manière
presque incongru entame des zergs et de
ragtime
et
à mesure qu'ils atteignent la mer les
canaux s'éloigne du navire par crainte
d'être entraînée par le naufrage du
paquebot certains ramènent en direction
des feux d'un navire que l'on aperçoit à
quelques milles seulement de là mais ce
navire ne sera jamais atteint
ni identifié et puis bien sûr il ya
toujours des menaces de poursuites
judiciaires même à ce jour savoir si le
navire qui était si proche de nous était
le californien ou pas je veux dire j'ai
vu ce navire terriblement proche et une
autre chose que je peux dire c'est que
je n'ai pas vu un navire à 19 milles de
là j'ai vu un navire qui était si proche
et on a dit à l'époque qu'il était à
moins de 9000
aujourd'hui il essaie de dire qu'il
était à 19000 je l' ai vu et ce n'était
pas seulement des lumières sur l'horizon
on voyait que c'était un navire et j'ai
vu qu'on lançait nos fusées ce bateau a
dû les voir et bien la commission d'
enquête a dit qu'ils les avaient
effectivement vu mais qu'il n'avait pas
pensé que c'était un signal de danger
mais j'aurais cru qu'au beau milieu de
l'atlantique en pleine nuit des fusées
devait signifier un navire en difficulté
la proue du titanic s'enfonce de plus en
plus pourtant toutes ces lumières vont
briller durant le naufrage jusqu'au tout
dernier moment avec un grand courage
chacun des mécaniciens du paquebot reste
à son poste dans les entrailles du
navire pour maintenir les pondre les
lumières la radio et les autres
fonctions en état de marche les femmes
et les enfants d'abord est la règle pour
les embarcations de sauvetage
toutefois on permet à certains hommes de
monter alors que les embarcations sont
précipitamment mis à la mer on ne peut
voir aucune dame à proximité
lorsque jack bruce ismay président de la
white star lui même nom dans une
embarcation à moitié plein les passagers
des première et seconde classe sont
conduits au pont des embarcations ceux
de 3e classe doivent se débrouiller
seuls pour trouver le chemin à 1h30 un
groupe assiègent l'embarcation 14 alors
qu'elle est sur le point d'être mise à
la mer et le 5è officier leur est
contraint de sortir son revolver et de
tirer en l'air le long de la coque pour
les calmer à 1h40
la dernière fusée lancée la dernière des
embarcations rigide
émise à la mer à 1h55 le pont des
embarcations et maintenant à quatre
mètres 50 au dessus du niveau de la mer
au lieu des dix neuf mètres habituels
ont réussi à mettre à la mer deux des
cas nos clients lorsque le troisième est
mise à l'eau à 2h05
le gaillard d'avant a été submergée et
l'eau envahit le pont promenade à sévère
ce moment que thomas saint john qui a
conçu ce grand navire est aperçue pour
la dernière fois dans le fumoir des
premières classes
il se tient debout les bras croisés sans
gilet de sauvetage fixant droit devant
lui une toile au dessus de la cheminée
la proche du port de pléneuf de norman
work and sun le capitaine snif décharge
les opérateurs radio de leurs
obligations
les philips continue d'envoyer des
messages de détresse tant qu'il ya du
courant le capitaine parcourt ensuite le
pont et déclare à ses hommes
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi
incroyablement les lumières bri encore à
2h10 le paquebot fait une embardée et
s'enfonce encore plus le dernier berton
et quelques hommes sont emportés du ruf
et ce canot de sauvetage b se retourne
en tombant à l'eau sans qu'il soit
possible de le redresser
des hommes se hisser avec difficulté sur
la coque retournée l'orchestré on a
maintenant un air solennel
certains disent automne mais la
tradition veut que ce soit plus près de
toi mon dieu
[Musique]
bien il ne fait aucun doute qu'ils
jouaient cela et il ne fait aucun doute
qu après que nous ayons été mise à l'eau
lors caisse rejouer une version de
l'hymne plus près de toi mon dieu dont
il ya trois versions je l'avais entendu
tant de fois et celle qu'il jouait était
celle qu'on entendait à l'église
quelques mois plus tard alors que
j'étais chez ma grand mère je n'ai
entendu à l'église et j'ai eu si peur
que je me suis précipitée dehors je
connaissait si bien la mélodie mais les
américains contestent cela et 10 non
c'était des mélodies de ragtime
mais ce n'était pas le cas
[Musique]
à présent l'arrière du navire se soulève
hors de l'eau deux câbles de soutien de
dix centimètres de diamètre se brise net
et la cheminée avant ça va brutalement à
tribord écrasant l'aileron de
passerelles et tuant plusieurs personnes
dans l'eau cela crée des remous qui
éloigne le canot retourné du navire les
témoignages diffère en ce qui concerne
la façon dont le commandant smith trouva
la mort une personne déclare qu'il s'est
suicidé de son revolver sur la
passerelle une autre qu'il a rejoint un
canot à la nage avec un bébé dans les
bras a placé le bébé dans le canot et a
disparu dans les vagues
une autre qu'il est simplement sombré
avec son navire peut-être at-il lui
aussi été tué par la chute de la
cheminée
d'autres encore disent qu'il a nagé vers
le canot retourné avant de se détourner
et de disparaître dans l'obscurité
1500 personnes se trouvent encore à bord
quand la passerelle est submergé
l'arrière se soulèvent très haut dans
l'air les occupants des embarcations
entendent le bruit fracassant des
chaudières qui se détache de leurs bases
et s'effondre à travers le navire de
même que des tonnes de charbon de
bagages tout le mobilier et les
installations de l'immense paquebot
au même moment les lumières faiblissent
clignote une dernière fois
puis s'éteignent
à présent on peut voir trente mètres au
moins de la poupe qui s'adresse presque
à la verticale
le navire est ainsi assez longtemps se
découpant sur le ciel constellé des
toiles dans la nuit calme est clair la
partie visible du navire se serait
légèrement rétabli avant de disparaître
à son tour dans les profondeurs c'est ce
rétablissement qui indique que le
paquebot s'est brisé en deux nous nous
sommes éloignés du navire aussi vite que
possible
il faut faire cela parce que l'effet de
succion provoquée par un navire qui
sombre est absolument énorme
nous avons ramé au loin je n'ai pas du
tout fermé les yeux j'ai vu ce navire
coulé j'ai vu ce navire se briser en
deux de nombreuses années les gens se
sont disputés avec moi à propos de cela
aujourd'hui enfin qu'il a été prouvé
sans l'ombre d'un doute qu'il s'est bel
et bien brisé en deux je sais qu'il
s'est brisé je l' ai vu la partie avant
a coulé en premier et l'arrière du
navire s'est dressé dans l'eau durant un
assez long moment du moins cela semblait
long puis il a basculé sur le côté et
nous avons entendu le bruit atroce des
gens qui se noyait ce qui est absolument
affreux
et puis parce que notre canot et est si
plein trop plein l'officier a rassemblé
les canaux et à transborder certains
d'entre nous un dans un canot deux dans
celui ci
trois dans celui là et j'ai été séparé
de ma mère et c'était la chose la plus
terrifiante qui pouvait arriver à un
enfant mais le bruit le plus horrible de
tous et le bruit des gens qui se noient
les cri terrifiant
ma mère disait parfois elle ne parvenait
pas à me faire parler de cela pendant
des années mais si jamais je mentionné
cela elle me disait mais te rappelles-tu
du silence qui est suivi cela et c'est
tout à fait exact
le monde entier s'est arrêté cette nuit
là une fois que les lumières avaient
disparu que le navire avait disparu que
les sons avait disparu or c'était
terrible
à présent il ne reste plus rien à faire
qu'attendre le sauvetage
parmi les hommes sur le canot retourné
se trouve à l'emploi et de l'opérateur
radio qui confirme à ses compagnons que
le carpathia est en route à 3h30
on l'aperçoit à l'horizon qui envoient
des fusées et à 4h30
il est sur les lieux
carpathia arrive avec l'eau et dès 8h30
il a pris à bord 700 cinq rescapés et
quatorze embarcations les canaux
restants ayant été laissé à la dérive et
nous avons été récupérés vous le savez
le matin par ce navire le carpathia et
le sauvetage de personnes dans un canot
oublié de l'océan est une chose vraiment
terrifiante ces petits canaux se sont
rangés disons faute d'une meilleure
expression le long de ce qui apparaît
c'est être un énorme vaisseau en fait le
carpathia était un assez petit navire à
ce qu'il paraît mais il semblait énorme
vu de l'arrière mais ensuite comment
monter rabat il n'y avait pas de
passerelle comme lorsqu'on est sur le
rivage
ils ont donc ouvert un je ne sais pas si
le terme est correct disons un panneau
dans le flanc du navire ou ont chargé
les bagages et ils ont lancé une échelle
de corps et les gens comme ma mère et
les autres adultes ont dû grimper en
plein milieu de l'océan à une échelle de
cornes qui se balançaient et elle m'a
dit que c'était la chose la plus
terrifiante qui soit
les marins dans les canaux tenait les
chaînes quant aux enfants
nous ne pouvions pas grimper à cette
échelle ils ont donc sorti de grands
filets à bagages dans les mailles sont
très espacées elles sont assez grandes
les enfants auraient glissé à travers
les jeunes enfants du moins nos jambes
et nos pieds serait passé à travers
ainsi chaque enfant famille dans un sac
je me souviens d'avoir été pétrifié de
terreur lorsqu'on m'a mise dans ce sac
quand resserrer autour du cou puis ont
placé les sacs contenant les enfants
dans ces énormes files et il n'y avait
pas de grands risques naturellement et
on les hisser à bord mais c'était
vraiment assez terrifiant une fois à
bord bien sûr je n'ai pas réussi à
trouver la mère est gelée cherché durant
des heures finalement je les retrouver
et je sais qu une des choses les plus
pathétiques que j'ai jamais vu durant
toute la journée suivante c'était ces
pauvres femmes comme ma mère qui
parcourait le navire pour essayer de
trouver le mari qu'elle avait laissé
derrière mais elle ne les trouvait repas
en route pour new york le commandant
rostron ne permet que soit envoyée par
radio que des messages officiels et
personnels
de ce fait les journaux en mal de copie
inventent leurs propres récits
fantaisistes du naufrage
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'à l'arrivée du navire que
l'on apprend la véritable histoire et
peu à peu la nouvelle du drame se répand
dans le monde
[Musique]
des messes de souvenirs sont dites de
part et d'autre de l'atlantique tandis
que les membres de l'équipage sont
détenus quasiment en état d'arrestation
jusqu'à ce que les enquêtes officielles
étaient effectués leur paye ayant été
bloquée à partir du moment du naufrage
la contreverse règne quant à
l'attribution de la responsabilité du
drame
de même que pour la question de savoir
si le navire à proximité le
californienne aurait pu effectivement
sauver toutes les personnes à bord
si seulement son opérateur radio n'avait
pas éteint son poste 20 minutes avant la
collision avec l'iceberg
les veilleurs avait bien vu et compté
les fusées mais avait pensé que c'était
probablement des signaux de la compagnie
utilisait pour l'identification des
navires qui n'était pas encore équipé
d'une radio
en outre elle paraissait trop base pour
un navire qui aurait été si proche la
commission d' enquête américaine rejette
la responsabilité sur jack bruce ismay
sur le fait que le titanic filet
pratiquement à pleine vitesse 21 noeuds
au moment de la collision
sachant qu'il y avait des icebergs à
proximité et sur le nombre insuffisant
d'embarcations de sauvetage la
commission denquête britannique la tribu
à la vitesse est la fourniture
inadéquate d'embarcations de sauvetage
mettant également en cause le capitaine
semaine suite à cette tragédie
il fut décidé que les navires suivent
une route atlantique plus au sud
vogt moins vite et comporte toujours un
nombre d'embarcations suffisant pour
toutes les personnes à leur bord 63% des
passagers de la première classe sur le
titanic survécurent 40% de la seconde
classe et 25% de la troisième classe
23% de l'équipage furent sauvés il y eut
705 rescapés en tout 1500 personnes
ayant péri dans les eaux glacées de
l'atlantique nord
mais la presse de l'époque se
concentrent moins sur la perte en vies
humaines et l'attribution de la
responsabilité que sur la façon dont les
valeurs anglo saxon d'héroïsme d'honneur
et de courage ont été respectées durant
toute la tragédie
les hommes se sont comportés ainsi que
le doigt toute sommes tous des héros
chacun d'entre eux et sur ceux qui
passent pour être les dernières paroles
du capitaine smith soyez britannique
[Musique]
paul loup
durant plus de soixante dix ans le
titanic repose dans les profondeurs de
l'atlantique sans être découvert
certains pensaient qu'il serait encore
intact que la corrosion serait minime
étant donné la profondeur à laquelle il
se trouve et qu'il pourrait être
renfloué le 1er septembre 1985 le nord
navire de recherche de la marine
américaine
rattaché à la woods hole oceanographic
institution découvre les parts au bout
de 76 ans on a enfin retrouvé le titanic
le professeur balla rld est à la tête de
l'expédition de nombreuses photographies
et images vidéo fascinante sont prises à
cette occasion et lors d'une visite
ultérieure au site en juillet 1986
le paquebot s'est brisé en deux sections
principales mais sa coque se tient
droite
ses cheminées ont disparu il s'est brisé
juste derrière l'emplacement de la
deuxième cheminée et la section arrière
se trouve à 800 mètres de distance
une grande partie de la section centrale
c'était par pie ix en fragments
fracasser sur le fond de l'océan
une plaque commémorative en argent a été
posée sur l'épave en signe de respect et
pour en faire le tombeau officiel des
centaines de personnes qui ont péri avec
le navire ainsi qu'on souvenir d'une
catastrophe qui n'aurait jamais dû se
produire
[Musique]
je suis entièrement d'accord avec les
mots de mon cher professeur balade
lorsqu'il a dit que tout cela avait été
un monument élevé à l'arrogance de
l'homme et je suis d'accord avec cela
les hommes avaient eu l'arrogance de
construire cette chose
et d'affirmer qu'elle était
indestructible si vous voulez c'est
incroyable il est vrai que si le titanic
avait heurté des rochers ou essuyer une
tempête ce serait toute autre chose mais
c'était un navire qui n'aurait jamais dû
causer la perte de vies humaines
c'est cela le plus affreux comme je les
dis toutes ces années après l'intérêt
est aussi fort parce que les gens
n'auraient pas dû mourir
personne n'aurait dû mourir s'il avait
comporté assez d'embarcations après deux
heures et demie sur une mer très calme
personne ne serait mort et une vie vaut
plus que n'importe quel navire n'est ce
pas c'est ce que j'ai vu c'est ce dont
je me souviens et il n'y a pratiquement
plus aucun d'entre nous avec qui
partager ce souvenir
je suis la seule rescapée en vie
aujourd'hui et puis s'en souvenir et qui
soit encore valide pour ainsi dire je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui
puisse vraiment raconter toute
l'histoire un par mois
[Musique]
oh